[Music]
has been my work over the last 10 years
trying to bring these communities
together to have this open discussions
about topics that have been taboos and
yeah thanks for that I grew to have been
able to create such a positive
atmosphere I see like a lot of smiles
around me in as I Shane said that this
is probably the most important topic to
have how these debates about and I think
it's kind of like my relationship with
Jurgis mid-to-upper there you are
I think it's like exemplified like a
good example of that spirit like me like
whenever we meet like we have like a
huge debates and like I'm kind of I
caught myself like yelling at you every
month no sorry about that
yet like every time we kind of leave we
are like I think we are gonna getting
better and better friends as a result
thank you
so yeah without further ado my talk my
favorite piece of parenting parenting
advice is to that when you want to
explain some picture kids treat them as
adults and don't dump down your answer
because its first of all it's like bit
of mischievous fun to watch them to try
to decode what you just said but more
importantly kids abilities increase over
time so if you dilute your explanations
you're likely to keep just constantly
undershooting interaxial intellectual
capabilities now my original plan for
this talk was to look back what has
happened in AI safety since the last fli
conference now key positive feedback for
achievements such as all the technical
value alignment work that has been done
take stock of the current challenges and
generally kind of congratulate the
community for coming together and
during majoring so quickly I even had
this prop here like I created a trough
where I where I would use this shirt
because I bought it from Puerto Rico
after my luggage was lost in transit but
then it occurred to me wait a minute
wouldn't that parenting advice apply
here as well wouldn't I just completely
undershooting the intellectual level and
the progress of this community so I just
read my draft and solid hour a new topic
we need a way to figure out what
humanity wants when I talk about value
alignment on in public one question I
almost always get is whose values are we
talking about and it is in response time
usually mumble something about the vast
majority of human values being so
obvious that we don't even think about
them as Stuart Russell puts it everyone
right lift the right leg or my own
favorite everyone likes our planet to be
roughly at room temperature that is not
to say that we don't have a problem with
aggregating our values we do a massive
one we don't know what a complete set of
humanity's values are not nor can we
simply ask people either since Staniel
Kahneman has pointed out there's a
difference between what people say what
they value and what they actually value
also our values are clearly a moving
target because they keep evolving over
time what's more we don't have a great
track record in coordinating on what we
already know is valuable the League of
Nations failed to prevent World War two
and although it although the UN has some
successes on under its belt such as
eradicating the smallpox and fixing
those on layer it's widely considered
well somewhat ineffective at this job
also free markets and democracy although
seemingly better than the alternatives
seem limited in their ability to steer
the world towards a bright future
especially if you think about the recent
events indeed I think that the biggest
disservice that capitalism has done to
the world is that it has created a false
sense of security in technological
progress not to mention the Tony
philosophical paradoxes with value
aggregation and even potential
dependencies on some unknown laws of
physics when we get down to the sort of
nitty-gritty of how the aggregation
value aggregation should work yet there
is hope first of all we now know much
more about morality human values and
game theory than we did when say the UN
was established second various new
technologies seem to favor global
coordination for example the internet
and Mobile's have connected the planet
cheap satellites and other sensors will
create an explosion in transparency for
better or for worse and the invention of
crypto economics has introduced a new
regime it's now possible to have
worldwide consensus about a piece of
data without trusting any central
authority to maintain it now I have many
examples but just to give one example
about what can be done with crypto
economics it's now possible to create
global decentralized courts and I got
this idea from Vitalik who is also here
in audience on block chains that resolve
conflicts by enlisting random people as
jury and then came terrifically
incentivizing them to produce opinions
that society in general would find fair
not to mention that the continued
advances in AI and techniques such as
inverse reinforcement learning and
approval director agents by paul
cristiano seem extremely relevant here
so therefore I'm proposing that we start
designing explicit mechanisms to
transparently and robustly
aggregate global opinion about what a
good future should look like the
mechanisms have to be open and
transparent blockchain style to instill
trust that their purpose is to serve
everyone in fairman
they have to be robust in the sense of
being hard to gain corrupt or otherwise
defecting and this probably requires
incorporating philosophical meta
principles such as veil of ignorance
that is you could only benefit from the
system as a random member of humanity
not as a particular person in a
particular position so basically I'm
advocating extending the technical
approach that has been very successful
in planting the frontier in AI safety
thinking to the problem of global
preference discovery about they are
safety thinking I think someone in
Cicero ffh I gave this wonderful
metaphor that the process that has been
unfolding in the last few years is like
sort of high-altitude bombardment by
very gonna prominent people the
canonical example of course Elon Musk
and Stephen Hawking followed by ground
troops of safety researchers so like
some people who are gonna still shooting
at airplanes might be doing so from
position that all it has been claimed by
safety research active sea safety
research of course all this new
technology can also make things harder
one man's coordination is another man's
collusion we have to be careful not to
catalyze criminal activity or worse
paint humanity into a corner but
introducing terrible Nash equilibria on
a global scale not to mention the clear
and present danger of various AI arms
races computer Nick just talked about
both literal and figurative we
absolutely need to avoid this and I know
this think topic has been on day misses
mind for a long time and finally the
looming AGI limits our time budget we
have lost over half a century since the
original warnings about AI value
alignment by Alan Turing and Norbert
Wiener a certain hope that we have still
another fifty but I know that several
experts in this room are much more
optimistic about their AI timelines and
thus pessimistic about our remaining
time budget last month there was a
workshop but FHI you know
we're one of the sessions was about what
to do if the value alignment won't be
solved in time and it had this eerie
atmosphere of a science fiction story
featuring an alien fleet in orbit aliens
who couldn't care less about humanity
and in a room full of decision theory
experts trying to find a philosophical
loophole that would allow humanity to
keep just at least one galaxy 100
billion one galaxy as a consolation
prize for the losers this 50% star
systems work for every human alive today
with that I want to illustrate to
talking two things first even if you
mostly screw up things might still turn
out to be pretty okay in the end and
second worst thing we could do is to
continue playing our usual political
zero-sum games when losing 50 galaxies
per second
luckily a transparent reference
discovery mechanism might serve as a
ladder for Humanity to climb out of the
arms races and other bad Nash
equilibriums it might also help with a
problem that many of you personally feel
society doesn't necessarily trust you
with the power you have over the future
grant that they might trust him more
than the politicians come on that's a
pretty low standard of course there's a
valid reason for that mistrust history
is littered with catastrophic tragedies
caused by individuals or movements that
amassed too much power I should know
that having personally experienced the
tail end of one such tragedy now imagine
if there was a way to credibly
demonstrate that I'm working towards a
future not just what you personally
thought was a good idea but towards the
future indicated by the global
preference discovery mechanism it's sort
of what open area people have been
talking about but on steroids finally
having a strong selling point for
humanity's values should be a great tool
for philanthropists effective altruists
and politicians who
we want to improve the human condition
and of course ultimately we want the
mechanism to converge into something
that can safely guide and superhuman AI
two years ago standing in front of this
conference I compared AI development to
launching a rocket initially you mostly
worry about having enough acceleration
but eventually steering should become
your primary concern the Sumer
summarized my current talk I would kind
of extend extend this metaphor to say
that now that day I research as a
process producing even more powerful
engines and the steering systems
designed by AI safety researchers is
also progressing it's about time to
start plotting or eventual trajectory
crucially the trajectory planning must
be globally transparent and fair because
everyone everyone will be on board thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]